let's walk through this it's very good
it's very filled with language that
we've developed over a long period of
time so it's very dense quickly so let
my pattern okay the first thing is this
paragraph is all about defining a
formula it's all about to find your foil
you've heard this word before but now I
want to give it a proper specific
definition so what in the bubble or
solid a formula is just like an equation
in fact pretty much every formula is
something something equals equals
something else
so it's an equation but it's not just
any equation it's a special kind what's
special about it it's a greater where
this subject I'm going to define this in
a second
the subject is a quantity we can
evaluate alright let's unpack that this
will be much easier if I give you an
example so only PR let me give you the
formula that covered in this first
question here C equals 2/5 R so this is
the formula for the circumference of a
circle the subject is this I only be
honest the subject okay
so this is a single variable on the left
hand side by itself let me say that
again it's a single variable or a single
chronium rule I should say it's a single
pro-europe if on the left hand side of
the equation and if by itself
so the subject of this equation is C the
circumference the circumference is a
quantity that witchity value you can
find out what is the circumference
what's it equal to if you have other
information so have a look at this
formula circumference equals what other
information do I need to put into this
to get the circumference moving on well
so pi is is a letter but it's just
another it's another we all could agree
on that we all work 3.1415 bla bla bla
bla bla but this R here is a piece of
Accession on
to like measure what is our paper really
is the rains so once you find the radius
you can substitute it and that lets you
evaluate the circumference okay so you
take your other efficient for like
radius and then you substitute it we
don't that is right take this out you
swap it for the correct value into the
right hand side everything you need to
put in the right here so for example you
could contract this to a very very
similar formula but one is backwards so
if I divide both sides by 2 pi and then
rearrange I'll get this do you agree
that's true what if I got to both sides
I have divided by 2 pi okay so this is
another formula it's still a formula
it's still an equation and has a subject
which is a simple pretty row left inside
by itself but it's not a formula for
circumference anymore is it
it's a 4004 radius if you know what the
circumference is she's got like a big
round together you wrap the string
around it that will tell you the
circumference that you substitute in and
that would give you the radius does that
make sense
now therefore since you can see what
I've done from here to here is the
subject used to be seen it used to be
the circumference and now the subject is
our now it's the Riesz this process from
here to here is called really important
process that is what 706 is about it's
called changing the subject because the
subject was one thing and then we just
rewrote it total something else okay so
really quickly for example let's have a
look at this one here I wonder how many
of you recognize what this formula is
without really lost all the context
around it already done it yeah this is
the Celsius to Fahrenheit formula okay
so one thing where you put your example
I'll just run out of space NPR
underneath we bring your example of this
circumference in Carmen C so C equals
five over
F - 32 this is a formula for the degrees
in Celsius give this other information
the degrees in Fahrenheit okay so for
example I don't know if IDEO there's a
like bid the US or Canada referencing
places that maybe we're in Fahrenheit I
think they say like a 100 degree
temperature it's really yeah okay it is
really hot right so can we find out what
would a hundred degrees Fahrenheit be
equivalent to in Celsius right so I
noticed something studio F equals R
hundreds
let's see what happens C will be equal
to 5 over 9 and I'm just going to write
101 100 minus 32 I've done by
substitution 100 take 132 is 63 8 is it
here what's five ninths of 68 30 so
appointed okay so this would be a hot
temperature for our for the day right
this to be pretty bad Saturday for us
but it's also important because it's
pretty close the body to preserve
resources so this is a formula for
degrees Celsius
given degrees Fahrenheit can we change
the subject what would we have to do to
change the subject so that F was the
subject what would be something we could
do start young what it suggests yeah
okay I could I can do a lot of things to
you this is a lot more complicated this
guy right I couldn't do this but I think
you'll find it'll be easier if actually
move this out of the way first so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to
multiply both sides by a number what
number will I multiply both side by they
don't get rid of 5 over 9 9 over 5 which
is called the
so if I multiply both sides by 9 over 5
that means we're is 9 over 5 C equals
what everyone's just that you can see
now assuming one step left to get F as a
single pretty rule the letter x by
itself what I did with my little buddy
all night don't shoot while I'm at it
I'll make F on the left-hand side so now
give it a certain temperature in Celsius
I can find that you're just in
Fahrenheit right so you can see that
I've changed the subject it's still a
formula but it's a formula for something
else that's all there is to it